before this crisis hazard cave kind of
little no an additional type of bonus
that you could get usually reserved for
military workers or miners who have
deemed you know dangerous jobs in early
March we started seeing an uptick in
kinases and that's where the panic
buying runs started show started letting
their they need to be stopped and as
that happen America's workers were
deemed essential they have been
advocating for a conditional pay better
safety more hand sanitizer on these jobs
not a great product and being someone
who's has a label as an essential worker
and taking pride in myself that I'm
helping in America right now but if you
tell the people that I work with that
they are as censored or workers they
don't believe that
[Music]
workers are frightened right now and I
think you're seeing a lot of the strikes
happening because of that I believe I
started around by 2002 and I have done
basically every job that my office
we're very short-handed right now and we
don't have a lot of land power right now
but they have given us an extra dollar
and if you ask me it was disrespectful
to offer me $1 for me coming to work
being an essential worker when I hear
other people around the area of that is
called a sensual worthless and may
company has tooken care of them I work
at a chicken company and do not have
chicken in my own freezer these
production lines move really fast
it's usually I pick 120 Birds a minute
and just think about how close you get
to be on these lines using they're
literally elbow-to-elbow
cutting chicken sawing off heads
separating breasts and this is serious
stuff when you're that close together
things can spread one book and they put
it on attendants so what they're saying
to the people is there if you come to
work all week long we will give you an
extra dollar so the people mean every
dime that they can strap together right
now so if somebody may be feeling sick
they're gonna try to come on just to
give that extra book when it's not even
really worth it I mean how can you give
a person four quarters and say that
we're trying to show you some gratitude
that's not gratitude to me it was being
disrespectful that's how I feel food
industry is actually America's biggest
employer with more than 20 million
workers there's around 3 million in farm
workers 2 million poultry workers stole
many restaurant workers
I'm hopeful that going forward as we get
out of this crisis that the work that's
been done to raise awareness about how
workers are treated and what these
conditions are like when they'll be
considered moving forward and it
shouldn't be something that is lost over
these unseen workers are crucial to our
food system and that's during crisis and
that's also not during a crisis
you